what do you want him at her ever since I
was a little boy I wanted to grow up and
marry the most beautiful woman in the
world so here I am with a thousand ships
and two good hands what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 update video this
will be a relatively short video but I
have always said I would keep you up to
date with any Game of Thrones news there
is a new spoiler which is compliments of
Watchers on the wall and this one has to
do with our one true Queen Cersei of
House Lannister according to this report
Cersei Lannister zhh body double has
been brought back for some additional
filming for the eighth and final season
her name is Rebecca Vaughn cleave and
you should remember her from the season
5 finale well I should say you might
remember her body because it was used
for Circe's walk of shame
I actually remember when I first watched
this episode I had no idea Lena Headey
was using a body double
I thought she had actually got naked for
the scene but I later found out it was
not her body they just added her head in
post-production what's interesting is it
looks like her casting agency actually
posted this on Twitter themselves which
is definitely a mistake on their part it
usually doesn't take too long for Game
of Thrones fans to sniff these kind of
things out and turn it into headlines
all over the internet in their tweet
they also said Rebecca would be
repeating her exact role for season 8 so
that means we will most likely see
Cersei Lannister naked again
since Cersei completely extinguished to
the faith of the seven in King's Landing
I doubt we will ever see her make
another walk of atonement so now the
question is why is Cersei Lannister
getting naked Jaime Lannister is no
longer there so we probably won't be
seeing any more sex scenes with them
either I do have a few different ideas
for why she needs a body double again
but I should preface this by saying this
is all speculation but I will base this
on a few things from season 7
as we all know Cersei Lannister has been
claiming she is pregnant and the reason
why I say like that is because I know
some people do not believe her but I
actually do I'm sure most of you are
aware that the entire plot leaked to
last season and it was amazingly
accurate the leak said Cersei would be
pregnant but it also said Cersei would
wake up in a bed of blood in the finale
they did end up cutting that scene out
of the finale obviously and I think they
did it because the episode was already
so long and I also believe they cut the
scene out to save it for season eight
they could use her miscarriage to set
the tone for Circe's actions next season
I believe when Cersei loses this baby
she's gonna go on a rampage because then
she would truly have nothing or no one
left which would ultimately mean Cersei
has nothing else to live for so I think
there could be one reason why we may see
Cersei naked in season eight there is a
very good chance we will see her wake up
in a bed of blood still if she did wake
up covered in blood
she might panic and start ripping her
clothes off or we might see someone put
her in a bath to clean her off or even
Qyburn may check her out afterwards to
make sure she's alright but those are
just a few options though another reason
why Cersei might be naked next season is
because of her alliance with euron
greyjoy in one of my previous videos I
talked about Euron possibly making some
more aggressive advances at Cersei now
that Jamie is gone since Jaime will no
longer be standing in between Cersei and
Euron he might see that as an
opportunity to get even closer to Cersei
if Cersei does happen to sleep with
Joran next season this could implicate
something very significant back in
season seven episode three you're on
told Cersei there is only one thing that
he wants and Cersei did say he can have
anything that has heart desires after
they win the war you've proven yourself
the greatest captain on the 14 seas and
a true friend to the crown you deserve
more than a true friend
you deserve a proper reward feel
there's only one reward I want what your
heart desires
I know war is one I think this is
something we need to keep in mind and
consider because of Circe's body double
was brought back to get naked again it
could be for a sex scene and if Cersei
is sleeping with your on this could mean
they were victorious she basically said
your own could have her after he helped
her win the war thanks to some of the
other set photos we know Winterfell will
come under attack next season and some
people have speculated that this may be
the golden company attacking or even
Circe's wildfire burning the Starks home
if they somehow managed to catch the
north with their pants down and sacked
the castle and burn it down Cersei may
let urine taste her Minj these are just
some guesses though there is one other
reason why I think Cersei may need a
body double next season and I think we
should also consider that this might not
be a nude scene the tweet did say it was
a repeat role but maybe they just meant
she was standing in for Cersei again and
not necessarily getting naked if that's
the case she may need this body double
because Cersei gets killed next season
if Cersei gets roughed up and strangled
to death
Lena Headey may have wanted someone else
to stand in to do that scene for her
I know it's still way too early to tell
what her role is gonna be but I'm not
gonna rule anything out it is the final
season and anything can happen depending
how bad of a death Cersei may have she
could need a body double to do it for
her but we're gonna have to wait and see
if any more developments come out these
are just a few of my initial thoughts if
you have any ideas that I did not
mention please put them down below in
the comment section because I would love
to hear them
I'm always open for suggestions I want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
watch this quick update video I
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank those of you who support
this channel on patreon have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]